when I see something not being done
right my first reaction isn't to go fix
it we don't think this is part of what
makes a great product we're gonna leave
it out some people are gonna not like
that they're gonna call us names it's
not going to be in certain companies
vested interests that we do that but
we're gonna take the heat because we
want to make the best product in the
world for customers a lot of people come
to me they say well I want to be an
entrepreneur and I go that's great
what's your idea and they go well I
don't have one yet and I say well I
think you should go get a job as a
busboy or something so you find
something you're really passionate about
what's that believe nation in seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Steve Jobs level
talent adds something and I want you to
find it embrace him and use it to make a
difference now I started that meant to
me series to try to hang on people
who've done a lot more than us and
hopefully by spending a little more time
with them some of their mindsets a way
of thinking seep into us to help us
become the best version of ourselves so
today we're gonna learn from one of the
best Steve Jobs and some of his best
business motivation also if you want to
know what Steve Jobs and other
entrepreneurs think about how to build
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you
for free a short 30 second a 5 minute
video to help you build your confidence
check out the link in the description
below a lot of people come to me they
say well I want to be an entrepreneur
and I go that's great what's your idea
and they go well I don't have one yet
and I say well I think you should go get
a job as a busboy or something till you
find something you're really passionate
about because it's a lot of work and I'm
convinced that about half of what
separates the successful entrepreneurs
from the non successful ones is pure
perseverance
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one don't compromise it seems like all
the good people I really want to hire it
seems to take me a year to hire him and
it's always been that way even at Apple
some of the best technical people or
whoever it always seem to take me like a
year to pry them out of HP or wherever
it took me it took me over a year to
high mining mike has the award you're
about a year and a half and they're all
worth it what happens is I usually meet
somebody that is really good I think is
very very good and you can't get them
and then you go try to find other people
and you know nobody measures up you know
when you meet somebody that good just
you always compare them this one person
you know you're gonna be settling for
second best if you compromise I've
always found it best not to compromise
and just keep chipping away rule number
two always ask why throughout the years
in business
I found something which was I always ask
why you do things and the answers you
invariably get are oh that's just the
way it's done nobody knows why they do
what they do nobody thinks about things
very deeply in business that's what I
found I'll give you an example when we
were building our Apple ones in the
garage we knew exactly what they cost
when we got into a factory in the Apple
two days the accounting had this notion
of a standard cost where you'd kind of
set a standard cost and then at the end
of a quarter you'd adjust it with a
variance and I kept asking why did we do
this and the answer was well that's just
the way it's done and after about six
months of digging into this what I
realized was the reason you do it is
because you don't really have good
enough controls to know how much it
costs so you guess and then you fix your
guess at the end of the quarter and the
reason you don't know how much it cost
is because your information systems
aren't good enough so but nobody said it
that way
and so later on when we designed this
automated factory for Macintosh we were
able to get rid of a lot of the
and equated concepts and know exactly
what something costs to the second so in
business a lot of things or I call it
folklore they're done because they were
done yesterday and the day before and so
what that means is is if you're willing
to sort of ask a lot of questions and
think about things and work really hard
you can learn business pretty fast it's
not the hardest thing in the world not
rocket science it's not rocket science
rule number three be a good leader I've
never believed in the theory that if
we're on the same management team and a
decision has to be made and I decide in
a way that you don't like and I say come
on buy into the decision you know buy
into it like we're all on the same team
you don't agree but buy into it let's go
make it happen because what happens is
sooner or later you're paying somebody
to do what they think is right but then
you're trying to get them to do what
they think isn't right and it ends
sooner or later it outs and and you you
end up having that conflict so I've
always felt that the best way is to get
everybody in a room and talk it through
until you agree now that's not everybody
in the company but that's everybody
that's really involved in that decision
that needs to execute it and so that's
how we try to run next the way we run
next is we have a team at the top we
call the policy team there's eight
people mike is on it I'm on it we have
six other people on it and the key this
we have two things we try to do one is
we try to differentiate between the
really important decisions and the ones
that we don't have to make and the
really important ones we work on it too
we all agree because we're paying people
to tell us what to do there's I don't
view that we pay people to do things
that's easy to find people to do things
what's harder is to find people to tell
you what should be done right that's
what we look for so we pay people a lot
of money and we expect them to tell us
what to do and so when you
when that's your attitude you shouldn't
run off and do things if people don't
all feel good about them and and the key
to making that work is to realize
there's not that many things that any
one team really has to decide and we
might have 25 really important things we
have to decide on a year not a lot so
that's that's how we try to run it
sometimes it works and sometimes we're
still working on it
I can't think of once I can't maybe
there's once or twice but I I can't even
recall a time when I've said dammit I'm
the CEO and we're doing it this way you
know I can't recall a time when I've
said we don't see eye to eye and you're
off the team
rule number four make the best products
things are packages of emphasis some
things are emphasized in a product some
things are not done as well in a product
some things are chosen not to be done at
all in a product and so different people
make different choices and if the market
tells us we're making the wrong choices
we listen to the market we're just we're
just people running this company we're
trying to make great products for people
and so we're we have at least the
courage of our convictions to say we
don't think this is part of what makes a
great product we're gonna leave it out
some people are gonna not like that
they're gonna call us names it's not
going to be in certain companies vested
interests that we do that but we're
gonna take the heat because we want to
make the best product in the world for
customers and we're gonna instead focus
our energy on these technologies which
we think are in their ascendency and we
think are gonna be the right
technologies for customers and you know
what they're paying us to make those
choices that's what a lot of customers
pay us to do is to try to make the best
products we can and if we succeed
they'll buy them and if we don't they
won't and it'll all work itself out rule
number five take a long-term view on
people I now take a longer-term view on
people in other words when I see
something not being done right my first
reaction isn't to go fix it
it's to say we're building a team here
and we're gonna do great stuff for the
next decade not just the next year and
so what do I need to do to help so that
the person that's screwing up learns
versus how do I fix the problem and
that's painful sometimes and my and I
still have that first instinct to go fix
the problem but that's taking a
longer-term view on people it's probably
the biggest thing that's changed and
rule number six the last one before very
special bonus clip is persevere a lot of
people come to me they say well I want
to be an entrepreneur and I go that's
great what's your idea and they go well
I don't have one yet and I say well I
think you should go get a job as a
busboy or something until you find
something you're really passionate about
because it's a lot of work and I'm
convinced that about half of what
separates the successful entrepreneurs
from the non successful ones is pure
perseverance it is so hard you pour so
much your life into this thing there are
such rough moments in time that most
people give up I don't blame them it's
really tough and it consumes your life I
mean if you're if you've got a family
and you're in the early days of a
company it's I can't imagine how one
could do it I'm sure it's it's been done
but it's rough I mean because it's a
pretty much you know an 18 hour a day
job seven days a week for a while so
unless you have a lot of passion about
this you're gonna not survive you're
gonna give it up so you got to have an
idea of or a problem or a wrong that you
want to write that you're passionate
about otherwise you're not going to have
the perseverance to stick it through and
I think that's half the battle right
there it's hard to remember how bad it
was you know in 1980s with IBM taking
over the world with the PC with Doss out
there it was it was far worse than the
Apple - they tried to copy the Apple -
and they done a pretty bad job and you
needed to know a lot and so things were
kind of slipping backwards and Macintosh
was you saw the 1984 commercial you put
that I hope you have that in your
archives
you know Macintosh was basically
this this relatively small company you
know in Cupertino California taking on
the Goliath IBM and saying wait a minute
your way is wrong this is not the way we
want computers to go this is not the
legacy we want to leave this is not what
we want our kids to be learning this is
wrong and we are going to show you the
right way to do it and here it is it's
called Macintosh and this is so much
better that it's going to beat you and
we are going to do it and that's what
Apple stood for
now I've got a really special Steve Jobs
bonus clip on how to be great at
marketing that I really think you're
gonna enjoy but before that I want to
make sure we're moving from watching a
video to actually taking action so I
have three questions for you to ask
yourself write the answers down for
yourself in a journal talk about them
with a friend or leave them in the
comments below here we go question
number one
what is one area in your business or
life that you compromise on too much
question number two how can your product
or service be the best in your industry
and question number three what will you
do to persevere when you feel like
giving thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
I'll see you soon and enjoy the bonus
clip
and we're always looking for excellent
models and goals and some people think
our goal with Mac is just to beat IBM
but what we really want to do is to pass
the largest install base of Mac's ever
this is our goal for the next hundred
days
seriously though I got a letter from the
vice president of marketing at
McDonald's among the many others that we
received and I'd like to just read a few
paragraphs of it
dear mr. jobs from one who appreciates
outstanding consumer marketing I
congratulate those at your company and
your dealers responsible for the
marketing of Macintosh and from one who
has wanted to be sold a personal home
computer I thank the same marketing
people at Apple for developing the
advertising insert which I recently
found in Newsweek magazine it did what
no other computer advertising nor
editorial information has done to date
it provided the reasons in rationale
which I needed to justify acquisition of
a personal computer for two years now
I've been trying to convince myself that
I should have a PC I've read lots of
advertising and many articles each time
to reach the same conclusion it's just
too much work to learn to operate one
what really would I do with one anyway
during this trying to be sold process
I've condemned the whole PC industry for
being completely ineffectual in their
consumer marketing efforts how could
people so bright enough to develop and
manufacture computers be so dull when it
came to selling them I actually
considered approaching you or one of
your competitors with some friendly
advice on marketing to the consumer no
need anymore
Apple has done it your Macintosh
advertising has sold me and you've shown
your industry how to market personal
computers to real people again a
professional crack congratulations and a
professional thank you to the marketing
team at Apple and all of your dealers
altruistic world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think I'm
saying it's a bloody brief life all of
you have the potential for enormous
success if you want to know what Gary
Vee DJ Khalid Oprah and others know
about empire building that most people
miss check out the link in the
description for a free bonus video